brings her up to the microphone
Celeste home that's all it's a great
pleasure thank you I had thought before
tonight that I had already received the
greatest reward that an actress can have
which is to play a part in a picture in
which one so wholeheartedly believes as
gentleman's green thumbs resents the
Oscar he thinks Survivorman
happy anniversary
mr. Coleman Thank You Olivia ladies and
gentlemen I am very happy
and very proud and very lucky lucky
because I know I wouldn't be standing on
this stage tonight without the grand
contributions of so many others for
great scripts and a great pot James bass
back
mr. James Academy wishes to give you
this honor thank you miss Bergman
now I know there's a Santa Claus oh you
may laugh ladies and gentlemen not so
easy to be certain you know he's our
most elusive little fella turns up in
all sorts of places under all sorts of
names in these guises first time I ever
met him for making the evening of my
life such a happy one
thank you very much thank you very much
everyone
Bob you don't mind I'd like to express
our appreciation to the editors for a
nominating body and soul to the hymn -
especially those who helped us in our
work thanks a lot
that's my heart you know up until now
presentations of the Academy Awards has
been a purely spectator sport for me
however tonight I dressed for the stage
just in case
because I had seen a new the beautiful
jobs done by the other four nominees
Roslin's
vitality and her great technical skill
in bringing that classic character to
life Jones expert craftsmanship in
pizzelle think fondly and possessively
of their country and of our industry
that can give them those thoughts and is
for you at long last
back in the Shrine Auditorium in the
Academy Awards with the winners
mentioned just a moment ago clustered on
the stage
the best picture
the personal Darryl zanuck the best
director Jean Hersholt has just
congratulated each one did you have a
happy birthday
Oscar thank you all yes and thank you
all for being with us tonight and I hope
we may be together again for many many
years to come
thank you and good night
you